this is a quick demo of how car
vibration and steering events can be
used to synchronize driving data the
video itself is a visualization of the
data streams we're working with the
audio you're hearing in the background
besides my voice is on my shotgun
microphone placed behind the rear right
tire the middle column has three images
each from a different webcam front
dashboard and face the dashboard video
has an overlaid steering wheel icon that
is visualizing the position of the
steering wheel as supported by the cam
Network the top left image shows the
dense optical flow in the video of the
forward roadway the bottom left just
shows our location and a map we're in
beautiful Cambridge Massachusetts and
the rest are plots showing the tenth
second window around the current
measurement of various sensors on the
left are the horizontal optical flow in
the front video and the steering wheel
position on the right are the audio
energy from the shotgun microphone the Y
component of the optical flow from the
three webcams and finally the z axis of
the accelerometer what we would like to
do is to synchronize all these senses
either online or offline as a post
processing step we do this by for
synchronizing the video of the forward
roadway with a can network by looking at
steering events
when you make a turn like the one coming
up here the horizontal optical flow will
be negative if it's a right turn and
positive it's a left turn the coming up
here is a left turn and you will see in
the top left image the dense optical
flow will light up all the same color it
will be a positive value since the left
turn we can then determine the optimal
shift the synchronization between a
steering wheel and the forward video by
computing the cross correlation function
the maximum value for the cross
correlation function to determine a
shift
and the same way we synchronized the
rest of the sensors with the video of
the forward roadway using vibration
events on the right are five plots
showing the audio energy the white
component of the optical flow for the
three webcams the z-axis of the
accelerometer each capturing the
vibration of the car caused by the road
a few examples are coming up shortly
here
so steering and vibration gives us a
signal that we can use for passive
synchronization
the result is a synchronized data set
which is important both for the analysis
of driver behavior and for the design of
a data systems they use decision fusion
to make real-time prediction based on
multiple sensor streams the paper along
with a sample data set and source code
are available in the description